so let's take a look at the structure of
paradise as it's presented in the in
Genesis so the first aspect of the
initial paradisal state is
unselfconsciousness now if you look at
factor at and out analytic studies of
human personality you note that
self-consciousness although it is
arguably our greatest gift also loads
almost entirely on the factor that
defines negative effect and you might
also notice that when you say I became
self-conscious you generally put a
negative cast on that in that I was
talking before a group of people and
suddenly I was seized by
self-consciousness and as a consequence
of that I was flooded by negative
emotion and was fundamentally
immobilized so it's a very paradoxical a
very paradoxical state of being that our
highest rational gift say and the only
one that clearly distinguishes us from
animals is also that which when
manifested makes us almost unbearably
anxious the initial paradisal state when
Adam and Eve first walk in the Garden of
Eden is characterized by an animal-like
unselfconsciousness Adam and Eve
whatever they are are not clearly
segregated from the rest of the world
they they have no idea for example of
their own nakedness and if you think
about what nakedness means you
immediately understand that that's also
a very profound dramatic representation
you know with children that around the
age of 3 or 4 many of them regardless of
their mode of upbringing start to become
very concerned about privacy say with
regards to bodily functions and also
very concerned about ever showing
themselves without clothing and it's
perfectly reasonable to presume that
that's a consequence of their emergent
self-consciousness an event that takes
place somewhere between the ages of 2 &
5 and that's a defining moment right
that makes them segregated we'll say
from their mother and so you also have
images of paradise that float through
Western history that are characterized
by the image of the unconscious union
between the mother and child right which
is a which is an imagistic
representation that eradicate s--
the tension of self-consciousness both
for the mother and for the child so the
notion that the child is living in a
paradise I'll condition that somehow
lost as he or she approaches adulthood
gives another sort of symbolic layer to
the notion of the pre self-conscious
paradise it's also a place where order
and chaos are in perfect balance and you
know that because what paradise means is
para around daisa a wall while eden
means delight or a place of delight
paradise a paradise is a walled garden a
walled place of delight and a garden is
precisely that place where the forces of
nature or chaos and the forces of
culture are held in perfect balance
right that's what a garden is its nature
given form by culture and it's a place
that's archetypal Pleasant a place where
the intervention of human activity has
produced a kind of stability that
transcends that of nature because it's
it's a cultural construct but also that
transcends that of culture because all
of the plants and the other growing
things that constitute a garden are
somehow transcendent even though they're
under the cultivating hand of culture
and the individual if you look at the
manner in which the fall story is
represented you all can also see that
the place of previous stability can be
regarded as a kind of paradise so if you
remember the story of Moses leading his
people through the desert it's clearly
the case that when the Israelites were
in the desert even though they got away
from the tyranny it was easy to look
back and say well you know tough as it
was the place that we were before was
much better than the place we are now so
it's perfectly reasonable and expectable
for people who were caught in a crisis
to look back to the time prior to the
dawn of that crisis with longing even if
the crisis that they're presently
experiencing is a necessary precondition
for further development of personality
so the story that's laid out in Genesis
has has its structure something like
this before we became self-conscious the
world was perfect
as a consequence of the rise of
self-consciousness we were thrown out of
the Garden of Eden out of paradise and
destined to live the profane existence
that characterizes our present mode of
being where were subject to knowledge of
mortality and the possibility of illness
and alienation from God and wouldn't it
be ever so great if we could only return
to that condition of unselfconsciousness
and make all our problems go away and
you see this kind of pathological
paradisal reminiscence manifesting
itself in the most banal forms of
conservatism which are always projecting
the ideal / the ideal past somewhere
back into the unattainable reaches of
time and also in those situations that
obtain psychologically when people are
absolutely possessed by depression and
anxiety and wish for their consciousness
to come to an end if not metaphorically
so they desire to sleep then actually so
that suicide is viewed as a kind of
unconsciousness whose paradisal nature
the absence of all opposition is viewed
as clearly preferable to the
difficulties of actually maintaining
being Ely Attis says the idea of
paradise once and then Paradise Lost is
not something unique to Western or Great
Eastern societies it's a widespread
motif just as wide as this as the flood
motif regardless of where you go in the
world you find this notion when heaven
had been abruptly separated from the
earth that is when it had become remote
as in our days when the tree or vine
connecting earth to heaven had been cut
or the mountain which used to touch the
sky had been flattened out then the
paradisal stage was over and man entered
into his present fallen condition in
fact all myths of paradise show us
primordial man enjoying a beatitude a
spontaneity and freedom which he has
unfortunately lost in consequence of the
fall that is of what followed upon the
mythical event that caused the rupture
between heaven and earth
as I said Eden is delight a place of
delight by terminological definition
whereas Paradise is a walled garden I
want to show you what knowing that does
for analysis of the relationship between
eastern and western thought so let me
tell you quickly the story of the Buddha
and I'm going to represent it
fundamentally like this Buddha starts
his life in what's essentially a walled
garden by all by all reasonable
comparative analysis and as a
consequence of his emergent
self-consciousness the unselfconscious
childlike perfection of that early state
is permanently disrupted
so you have a situation where the
greatest Redemption story of the East
follows precisely the same grammatical
track as the greatest creation story of
the West so this is the story
Buddha's father is visited by an angel
who tells him that his son is going to
grow up to be the greatest temporal
profane ruler the world has ever seen or
a great spiritual leader and his father
being a pragmatic and conservative man
decides that there's no possible way I'm
going to allow my son to take the
ambivalent road of spiritual
enlightenment I'm going to allow him to
fall completely in love with the world
so that he will remain attached to his
domain
so prior to Buddha's birth his father
constructs a great city with walls
around it and inside that city he
removes all signs of pain frustration
and disappointment
any sign of ugliness the and age the
only people that are allowed to exist
within this city are those who are in
perfect mental and physical health who
are Paragons of beauty and virtue and
the idea that lurks behind that
archetypal story is that when a father
has a child the his moral obligation is
to shield the developing consciousness
of that child from contact with any of
the horrors of life
that could provide the child with an
experience too traumatic for that
developing consciousness to apprehend so
because it's an archetypal story it
relates to the development of all people
not just the redemptive Savior and
that's the motif that the Buddhist story
initially follows a good father makes
his child fall in love with life by
enticing that child into a direct
relationship with all that life has to
offer so Buddha grows up within this
walled garden this unselfconscious
paradise but precisely because he's been
shielded to this degree and allowed to
mature his consciousness continues to
expand and the world outside the
boundaries that his parents have
established for him
starts to attract his attention now we
know already that the forbidden fruit
right the lure of what's outside the
walls is something that human beings
just can't keep their mangy little paws
off right
we are absolutely uncontrollably curious
and the best way to make sure that we
investigate something is to lay down a
stricture that says whatever you do
under whatever circumstances never look
there right and then the automatic
systems that underlie our orienting and
that motivate our seeking experience are
constantly pulling our attention
precisely to that forbidden spot
compelling us to investigate exactly
that which has been forbidden so because
Buddha is a consciousness developing in
a healthy manner he immediately becomes
curious about what lies beyond the the
limits that have been established with
him and he makes a decision to go
outside of paradise right which seems a
particularly ridiculous thing to do
given that in principle he has
everything he could possibly want inside
the walls but then again we have the
Troublesome notion of the original sin
of Adam right which is that if any of
you were offered a forbidden fruit again
under circumstances mythologically
equivalent to those that obtained in the
beginning you'd immediately reach your
hand out and take it because what we
haven't got for human beings is always
far more compelling than what we have
got
so Buddha goes outside the walls but his
father was a good father although
somewhat conservative decides he's gonna
rig the game a little bit so he gets rid
of everybody that's diseased or unhappy
or uncomfortable or ugly or old or
anything that could possibly disturb the
Buddha and he lines the streets with
flour waving women and puts pedals on
the road and sends his son out in a
gilded chariot but the gods who are
lurking around right the troublemaking
gods who represent chaos and disorder in
the unknown desire to send in front of
Buddha a sick man who hobbles unsteadily
into view and Buddha asks his his
retainer precisely what this phenomena
represents and his retainer says well
you know human beings like you since
you're human are subject to the
deterioration of these their physical
powers in an arbitrary way and this man
is one person who's being so afflicted
and so Buddha is completely disenchanted
by his exploratory move out into the
terrible unknown and runs back into the
castle walls and shuts the door it is
perfectly happy to think of nothing for
months but then as his anxiety
habituates and his curiosity grows he
can't stand the notion of never going
outside the walls again and outside he
goes again and this time we're after his
father prepares the route ever so
carefully the godsend in sight an old
man who hobbles into view and Buddha
looks at him in shock and horror and
says to his retainer just precisely
what's going on here and his retainer
says well that's an old man and
everybody gets old and you're going to
get old too and that's the way of all
humanity and that's the point at which
Buddha's self-consciousness expands not
to only include the possibility of
degeneration but to include the temporal
horizon that's characteristic of life
and he finds that so terribly shocking
that he runs back into the castle and
shuts the walls down and plays with his
friends for another six months or maybe
a year till his anxiety finally
habituates and he goes out one final
time and this time the gods send a
funeral
parade for him and he sees his first
dead body and this is such a terrible
shock to him that he can't even go back
to the castle so his father prepares for
him a great party in the woods near the
castle full of nude dancing women who
are perfectly willing to flaunt
themselves and to offer themselves to
him but Buddha is so absolutely a
catastrophic we shocked by this notion
of emergent death that he can't take any
pleasure whatsoever and what's being
offered to them and he leaves the
kingdom once and for all and you think
well that's exactly what happens to you
when you grow up right if you're
reasonably well socialized and properly
looked after then your curiosity gets
the better of you and you keep going out
into the world until what your parents
have established for you is no longer
sufficient for you and as a consequence
of that movement own into the world you
find out all sorts of things
characteristic of your own life that not
only your parents can't precisely
explain to you but even the broader
formal structures of your culture have a
very difficult time handling and when
you finally do encounter such realities
and allow their effect on you to fully
manifest itself well then you're finally
independent and you no longer can return
home but from that point forward you're
also burdened as Adam is burdened when
he loses his paradisal
unselfconsciousness with the full
revelation of what it means to be
limited and alive so what happens to
Buddha as a consequence of this
revelation he becomes an apprentice and
The Chronicles of the Buddhist adventure
are careful to say that he becomes the
world's most proficient practitioner of
samkhya which was a philosophical
precursor to yoga and then to yoga so he
masters all the positions in the asanas
until he's disciplined physically to an
almost unlimited degree and then he
decides that he'll adopt a stance of
world renunciation which is also
something he's remarkably good at and he
starves himself until the chroniclers
say he resembles nothing so much as a
pile of dust and then having exhausted
all the disciplinary structures that his
sophisticated culture has to offer him
but still not precisely find
the answer that he's looking for he
retreats into the forest place of the
unknown and sits himself at the base of
a tree underneath the tree he's visited
by visions and temptations the first
vision is an essentially erotic one life
itself tempts him back out of his
self-conscious state into the domain of
pure physical pleasure a perfectly
reasonable temptation right and one
that's powerful enough so that Hindu
philosophers say be as their churches
and cathedrals are covered with erotic
drawings if you can't get past the
erotic drawings into the church that's
the domain that you should still inhabit
right in the dawning phases of life at
least till middle age that's the
appropriate mode of being to be enticed
and seduced by the physical pleasures
that life has to offer but in the final
analysis those are not sufficient to
solve the problem of emergent
self-consciousness and so the angel of
death visits him and offers him the
opportunity to exist permanently in a
state of Nirvana a very very interesting
twist on the story because you have to
wonder given the association say between
suicidality and the notion of paradise
that exists underneath that if what
Buddha isn't being offered by the angel
of death is in fact death and the
cessation of all the problems of being
regardless he rejects that attains
enlightenment briefly and then decides
to return to the world to share what
he's discovered with all of suffering
humanity the idea being that the Buddha
who is the awakened or enlightened one
is capable of attaining a transcendent
state but also knows fully that because
human beings have a shared social aspect
it is not possible for any one person to
attain Redemption until all people
attain Redemption the reason being that
it's very difficult to be transcendent
and enlightened when you see someone
who's sick lying in a ditch
so then we shift from that back to
Genesis and the tempted fall of man and
read the third chapter and they were
both naked the man and his wife and
we're not ashamed well what does that
mean well Freud pointed out that one of
human beings most common nightmares is
to be stripped of clothing in front of a
crowd now why would that be precisely
well your naked self is the most
vulnerable aspect of you right we're all
clothed and for good reason partly
that's protection from the terrible
natural world right but it also offers
this the possibility of placing a
barrier between ourselves our vulnerable
cells and the searching and critical
gaze of the community right because not
only are we vulnerable to the rigors of
nature we're also vulnerable to the
depredations and criticisms of society
and the notion that a man and a woman
could exist naked and not know it is a
clear is a clear finger pointing in the
direction of a story that says these
people were not conscious or if
conscious they certainly were not
self-conscious and what's how does the
story develop the serpent was more
subtle than any beast of the field which
the Lord God had made and he said unto
the woman yea hath God said you shall
not eat of every tree of the garden and
the woman said unto the serpent well we
made of the fruit of the trees of the
garden but of the fruit of the tree
which is in the center of the garden God
hath said you should not eat of it
neither shall you touch it lest you die
and the serpent said to the woman you
won't die for God knows that in the day
you eat thereof then your eyes shall be
opened right a clear pointing to the
notion of an awakening and an
illumination and you should be like
God's knowing good and evil right which
attributes to humanity a dawning sense
of morality explicit morality a faculty
for comprehension that we do not share
with any other and
and when the woman saw that the tree was
good for food and that it was pleasant
to the eyes and a tree to be desired to
make one wise she took of the fruit
thereof and did eat and gave also unto
her husband with her and he did eat
women trouble
what's the tree well we talked about
this a little bit before so you say well
if you look at the structure of
experience from this particular
perspective and you think about that in
a vertical plane with the layers one on
top of another then you can imagine the
tree as the thing that unites these
three layers the tree is the domain that
unites chaos and order and the
individual the structure running up
through the middle of it and you see a
representation of that interestingly
enough from Norse mythology this is a
Druze L the the tree of the gods that
the tree that stands in the middle of
the Norse paradise and one of the things
that's very interesting about this
particular tree is that if you look at
its roots its the roots are covered with
snakes and serpents and underneath the
snakes and serpents is water and so that
you see that the tree it stands at the
center of the world is rooted in chaos
fundamentally is rooted in whatever it
is that constitutes the pre cosmogonic
matrix of being and then the central
aspects of this domain are nicely laid
out as the domain of territoriality the
ends of the borders that the individual
understands in the habitual territory
that he inhabits and then the tree in
the center represents whatever it is
that's central to this to our mode of
being and so let's take a look at that
in some detail and flesh it out
symbolically we find Iliad is saying the
tree that stands hypothetically at the
center of the world is precisely that
structure that shaman climb when they
make their transition from the normal
mode of earthly being into their
transcendent mode of being so Elliot
says the symbolism of the ascension into
heaven by means of a tree is clearly
illustrated by the ceremony of
initiation of the bouriette shaman the
candidate climbs up a post
in the middle of his yurt his tent
reaches the summit and goes out by the
smoke hole but we know that this opening
made to let out the smoke is likened to
the hole made by the pole star in the
vault of heaven so you can imagine
there's a conceptualization of the world
as centered around a particular axis and
that the tent is regarded as at least
trans transitory as a symbolic
equivalent of that cosmological
structure among other people's the tent
pole is called the pillar of the sky and
is compared to the pole star around
which the world rotates at least from
the visual perspective and is named
elsewhere the nail of the sky
thus the ritual post setup in the middle
of the yurt is an image of the cosmic
tree which is found at the center of the
world with the pole star shining
directly above it by ascending it the
candidate enters into heaven that is why
as soon as he comes out of the smoke
hole of the tent he gives a loud cry
invoking the help of the gods up there
he finds himself in their presence the
tree is an absolutely archaic symbol and
it seems to me most likely that it
represents the structure of the nervous
system I think a structure that's rooted
not so much in the spinal sensory motor
structures but deeply in the autonomic
structure stretching down into the
center of the body and planting the mind
firmly in its material substrate so that
the autonomic system and its projections
up into the amygdala and the limbic
system and then up into the cortex
constitute the interface between the
spiritual domain that our psyche
inhabits and the material domain that
constitutes our body the tree at the
center of our being what does a tree do
well it bears fruit well what sort of
fruit well there are multiple medieval
representations that are quite peculiar
showing Christ for example as the fruit
of the tree of the knowledge of good and
evil the fruit of the tree of life and
what does that mean it means that
conceptualizations like the hero are
products of whatever it is that this
tree represents the tree is something
that produces fruit fruit is also
something that can be ingested
and as Eric Newman point out wherever
liquor fruit herbs etc appear as the
vehicles of life and immortality
including the water and bread of life
the sacrament of the host and every form
of food cult down to the present day we
have an ancient mode of human expression
before us so imagine the idea of the the
piagetian idea of assimilation and then
accommodation and then understand its
assimilative nutritive underlying
metaphorical nature the idea being that
there's a tight analogy between
ingesting something material and
undergoing a transformation of energy
attendant upon that right which is what
happens when you eat and ingesting a
piece of information which offers you a
new mode of doing things so you can say
well people will trade work for
information they will trade food for
information there must be a kind of
equivalence between work and information
and food and information because
otherwise the trade wouldn't make sense
and then you realize that if you're
informed you can undertake
transformations of yourself and the
material world in a much more efficient
manner because that's what being
informed means and that means that being
informed acquiring some information and
eating something are all tied up in a
complex way into the same metaphorical
structure eat something forbidden
transform as a consequence conscious
realization is acted out in the
elementary scheme of nutritive
assimilation and the ritual act of
concrete eating is the first form of
assimilation known to man the
assimilation and Jess tchen of the
content the eaten food produces an
interchange transformation of the body
cells through food intake is the most
elementary of animal changes experienced
by man how a weary enfeebled and
famished man can be turned into an alert
strong and satisfied being or a man
perishing of thirst can be refreshed or
even transformed by an intoxicating
drink this is and must remain a
fundamental experience so long as man
shall exist
Eric Newman's point being that our
psychological experience of the capacity
of psychological transformation through
eating is a metaphor waiting to be
applied to the equivalent experience
that we obtain the equivalent of
excitement and sense of transformative
possibility that we acquire as a
consequence of coming across some new
and truly valuable piece of information
so you have the idea that the tree that
stands at the center of the world the
individual mode of being is something
that bears fruit and the ingestion of
that fruit that IDSA or that that piece
of information is something that can
produce a permanent transformation
you